across the globe but one royal era is
ending in Japan this morning and another
is beginning 85 year old Emperor Akihito
is abdicating the throne to make way for
his oldest son it's the first time in
more than 200 years that a living
Japanese emperor has stepped down
Elizabeth Palmer is in Tokyo for the
historic handover of authority to mark
the occasion the entire country is
enjoying Golden Week which is in fact 10
whole days of national holiday here in
Tokyo people are gathering outside the
Imperial Palace where this hugely
respected Emperor is saying his final
goodbyes in a short ceremony Akihito
thanked the people who supported him and
said he was fortunate to have servants
upon a time the Emperor was considered
divine and even now the job is
overwhelmingly ceremonial with no
political power for 30 years Akihito
simply represented the unity of Japan to
his people and to important foreign
guests but in his own way a kokuto has
tried to break the mold his aloof father
Emperor Hirohito considered himself
descended from the gods but had to
renounce his divinity after surrendering
to US General MacArthur at the end of
World War two by contrast Akihito works
to project his human son
he's a musician he met his wife
Michiko playing tennis she's the first
commoner ever to marry into the royal
family and together the royal couple
works to connect with common people for
example visiting survivors of the 2011
tsunami Akihito is stepping down to make
way for his son 59 year old Naruto who
along with his Harvard educated wife
Masako will take the throne overnight so
what does an emperor do in retirement
well one of Iquitos passions is marine
biology he says he's going to continue
studying fish while his wife says she's
just gonna catch up with her reading for
CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo Thank You
Elizabeth